die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen tagen im
hintergrund dazu bei
klar die blanke fällt bäume im engadin
riether streule kontrolliert palette bei
den zürcher verkehrsbetrieben hansjörg
schweizer markiert signalisationen auf
appenzell straßen und sabina führt einen
so im tessin
wie leben diese menschen wofür setzen
sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und der alltag ein tag im leben der
schweiz
kurz vor halb vier in urdorf bei zürich
die 28 jährige rita und allein
[Musik]
kurz später in appenzell der 47-jährige
hansjörg steht ebenfalls gerne früh auf
[Musik]
ein herstellungs von rita ist bereits
auf dem weg zur arbeit die quirlige
busfahrerin hat immer das gleiche ritual
[Musik]
wenn ich das gehört habe sei kein hobby
beck bekam ich zurückhaltend
[Musik]
im unterengadin der 30 jährige klar
durch geht den tag langsam an seine frau
und die drei kinder schlafen noch
das war schon was morgen ist ein joghurt
braucht es fast sonst muss man die
restlichen neun machen klar die ist in
stein aufgewachsen
es könnte schon sein dass ich vielleicht
mal weggehen aber eigentlich lebe ich
gut hier
zürich riether muss ihren fuß fassen
ich bin als claire und die köchin und
bin durch ein großer zufall bin ich so
fahre ich bin ihm ausgangs in zürich und
vevey und haben es plakate für die vbz
wo sie geschrieben dass sie gerne
größeren frauenquote hätte tja und auf
das habe ich mich eigentlich beworben
nicht dass - das ist der frauenanteil
bei den verkehrsbetrieben zürich kurz
vbz liegt bei 18 8 gesamthaft sind 1300
leute im einsatz
in appenzell hansjörg nimmt sich am
morgen immer zeit für seine hasen zucht
er ist einer von rund 10.000 ringer die
züchter in der schweiz
hier ist der grafikkern idar ii krise
habe da seien jetzt die jungen die
weniger geld die grüne straße und motor
der schweiz anerkannte für die stelle
gelöscht und dann geht es nicht ganz so
viele schöne rock gehören dort es lang
geht so einfach möglich gehalten das
fällt nicht ganz schön ich zum
aussteller die selber machen mit den
schultern
es ist 7 im sofa man ja so ist es noch
ruhig rabbiners hier aufgewachsen
ihre eltern waren vor 44 jahren von
basel ins tessin gezogen und hatten
diesen zoo gegründet vor drei jahren hat
nun sabina die leitung übernommen und
vor kurzer zeit ist sie mit 44 selbst
noch mutter geworden
ihre mutter hat denn so die letzten 20
jahre alleine geführt
ihr freund federico kümmert sich um
alles technische hier
sabine hat zehn jahre lang andere jobs
gemacht bevor sie zurückgekommen ist
aber für sabine und ihre fünf
angestellten gibt es sehr viel zu tun
und so lang so gut versteckt dass gut
im wald unterhalb von spur juli ist mit
zwei lehrlingen unterwegs sie müssen
bäume fällen weil diese den
stromleitungen im weg sind
[Musik]
wenn man gerne in der natur ist und
keine körperliche arbeit leistet und
gerne die eine oder andere arbeit mit
maschinen macht ja dann nimmt man auch
die gefahren in kauf
in den letzten zehn jahren hat es drei
größere unfälle gegeben bei einem ist
ein lehrling gestorben
wegen der gefahren seid meine familie
hat schaut man vielleicht schon mehr auf
die eine oder andere sache aber ganz
verhindern dass so etwas passiert kann
man dieser hier na ja aber wenn ein
richtig großer baum zu boden fällt dann
ist das schon etwas schönes
zurück im tessin sabinas tochter lisa
ist aufgewacht
ihre mutter edith hat eine neue aufgabe
die stabsübergabe zwischen den beiden
frauen waren nicht ganz einfach
[Musik]
ja jetzt nach drei jahren krank durch
das ich weiß ich habe eine zeit für
alles und ich glaube das glück so
selbstständig wie möglich sind also die
angestellte und hat dementsprechend ich
wirklich leicht im motor hingegen hätte
alles müsse die kontrolle also lisa wex
gleich wie sabina im zoo auf und sabina
ist froh dass sie und ihre mutter eine
gute arbeitsteilung gefunden haben
kurz nach 8 in appenzell hansjörg
arbeitet den straßenunterhalt
heute müssen er und seine beiden kumpels
die mittelstreifen auf der
kantonsstrasse von appenzell richtung
schlag kassel neu malen
hansjörg ist der einzige im kanton der
die maschine bedienen kann
[Musik]
diese stoffe wie spielen oder mit wenig
gewicht wieso und aber viel zu hektisch
sondern
großvater war es am land prozent oder
nicht wenn sie harmonisch aber die
gefahr ist nicht das was er am
schlimmsten findet
die nähe von nämlich aber wenn man sich
und die stapo selber wegwerfe überall
der allmend gewann die mannschaft den
apple fans machen sich ganz anders
stoßzeit in zürich jeden tag benutzen
rund eine million menschen die vbz
rita ist seit drei stunden unterwegs
kleine verkehrshindernisse wie diese
führen logischerweise zu verspätungen
das schätzen die fahrgäste gar nicht
meistens der haltestelle zeigen
absichtlich sport moment wird alles ist
alles besser aber es gibt auch immer
wieder freundliche begegnungen
sind sie gut die strecke ist so im
fußball
[Gelächter]
wichtig dass nur das gegenüber
wertschätzt egal ob das jetzt selber ein
job wäre ich ein buch das über dich wo
mobile schutz in der hektik schaffte hat
container tut lehrer jede hat sind teil
der schweiz und es ist wichtig dass man
einfach jeder genau gleich behandelt so
wie man selbst behandelt werden
zurück in den bergen pause für die
förster
es ist vielleicht schon ein bisschen so
dass die holzfäller nicht diese intim
presse reden sie arbeiten lieber mehr
als sechs millionen bäume werden
jährlich in der schweiz gefällt alles
muss wieder aufgeforstet werden
die holzpreise sind momentan tief das
holz hier geht zum teil in die sägerei
von taras der größte teil wird jedoch
nach italien oder österreich verkauft es
ist 11 eine von sabinas lieblings
aufgaben ist die fellpflege von jimmy
der gibbon affe ist zehn jahre älter als
sie und hat sie schon durch ihr ganzes
leben begleitet jedes bedächtig und das
zeigte genau und es bieten sich die
spinnenart ohligs moment begonnen haben
sabinas eltern mit einem kranken löwen
mittlerweile leben rund 220 tiere hier
der kleine privat so hat das
pflegestation begonnen
in der zwischenzeit macht er auch bei
zuchtprogrammen mit nur etwa vier der
rund 30 zoos in der schweiz sind privat
sie werden von tierschützern besonders
stark bekämpft wo sie die gleichen
regeln einhalten müssen wie die großen
das tierschutzgesetz drogen stand
verbessere und das ihr eigenes genre
landrat thema jahren gelang der lage
größere naturtheater reduzieren quartal
lagen einfach denn zu größeren und
einfach immer wieder mit billiger machen
und wenn wir über neue vorsichtig hätten
wir ja so und so lang zum das vor
anderen dass man einfach immer lockt das
dass die neue struktur denn damit sprach
er die narren manchen sogar damit zu
quatschen
[Musik]
mittag in der schweiz hansjörg immer
nach hause zum essen
[Musik]
nur zwei der vier kinder es noch geheim
aber er hat immer noch andere kinder
hier ja ja benjamin jüngster hat eine
schwere stoffwechselkrankheit die das
gehirn angreifen würde wenn er nicht
eine strenge diät einhalten würde
entdeckt wurde sie kurz nach der geburt
nur eins von 90.000 kindern in der
schweiz ist betroffen
lange soll das dann auch die geburt
excel kann mich gefreut haben wir getan
richtig gewagt kräfte geburt und den
kontakt telefon und handy während der
fahrt elend lang und für musik gedanken
juristische welt thema brauchen im
moment
mittlerweile haben sich alle daran
gewöhnt doch es hatte schon auswirkungen
auf die familie vor allem für manuela
noch ganz plant ihre lose verkaufen will
haben ideen ja irgendwie bei dem g einer
kollegin oder einer großmarkt zum
hochmoor ist entschieden
das enorme wirtschaftliche und irgendwie
an die dänen wollen inserat lässig dass
der tagesmutter so achtet und habe ich
den groll der frau gekannt immer wieder
untersuchen wir zusätzlich sind
klar du ri und seine kollegen essen im
wald heute hatten wir sehr viel fantasie
[Musik]
gewisse sachen koche ich einfaches kann
ich schon machen aber nicht dass ich
jetzt dann kochkurs oder so gesucht
hätte manchmal muss man einfach
ausprobieren und wenn es gut ist dann
macht man das nächste mal das gleiche
und sonst macht man etwas anderes oder
auch andere sachen kann ich schon machen
[Musik]
zurück in zu sabine freund nico ist
eigentlich koch kurz nachdem sich die
beiden vor neun jahren kennengelernt
hatten entschied sabina dentsu zu
übernehmen
federico hat mitgezogen und das macht
ihm spaß
großmutter edith hat gekocht
die junge familie lebt vorläufig in
ihrem haus sie möchten gerne aufstocken
aber die baubewilligung verzögert sich
rausholen und füllt gern für andere ich
jetzt wirklich tun situation also im
moment profitieren muss ich so gesehen
wir haben teil vor ist das auch mit nun
ein großer teil
[Musik]
als eddie house den jungen übergab
musste sie erst mal für eine weile weg
sie hatte mühelos zu lassen aber nun hat
sie sich daran gewöhnt
[Musik]
einfach so
zurück in zürich liter hat nur schnell
ein sandwich verdrückt jetzt macht sie
bietet kontrolle
meist arbeiten sie in gemischten teams
[Musik]
dank ihm einen schönen tag tragisches
lächeln bringt und kürzesten wenn ich
schon halb fertig macht dementsprechend
begegnet die örtlichen so viel
freundlichkeit und darstellungen sind
eher bereit der den vorzeige wenn es
jetzt darum gott wie eine tüte kreis
qualität der wiese gelockt und dann sich
selber ganz sicher kreisten sie so dass
da wo viel licht ist in den schritt was
denn da wirklich gar nicht und dann
wahrheit des jahres aber die strategie
mit der freundlichkeit funktioniert
meistens aber nicht immer
ritter wurde auch schon tätlich
angegriffen
der fahrgast ist vom leo xiii
und es ist ein gigantisches explodiert
und danach
wohnungswechsel wahrheit schlagen keinen
sinn berg hat eine spieldauer ist er
sich zum glück nimmt in ich kann
liebende schade und ich jetzt noch an
weswegen ich zähle das lumix für
management wenn mit europas wo
alkoholisierte schon gar nicht mehr
jungs rastatt aber es ist eigentlich
alles gut auffangen
[Musik]
im appenzellerland damit linie wie sie
kantonsgericht sowie andere nur das team
mache also schöne strich sie für
hansjörg ist das hier sowieso der
schönsten flecken auf erden böse sache
speziell ja ich werde mir solche brk
schmaler als apples jetzt vielleicht
nicht so einfach denn die kulissen und
mehr dahin sei bis auf weitere staaten
innerhalb von minuten schlägt das wetter
um den stützpunkt ein richtiges gewitter
geduld haben die herren dann doch nicht
so viel
rund 1000 kilogramm farbe wetter allein
auf den 65 km straße im kanton appenzell
jedes jahr vermalt fast 18.000 kilometer
kantonsstrassen gibt es in der ganzen
schweiz
[Musik]
traurig
naja du
rund 35.000 menschen besuchen den zoo
von malia so jedes jahr löhne und
futterkosten fressen die einnahmen aber
auf mio für sie waren
im gegensatz zu den großen zoos ist es
für sabina schwierig an großzügige
spenden gelder heranzukommen so
dankeschön institution wo man einfach
mehr bieten als gelernte pr frau
versucht sabina mit veranstaltungen wie
kinder geburtstagen und hochzeiten
zusätzlich geld zu verdienen
das sind auch gute gelegenheiten die
besucher für die tiere zu
sensibilisieren
[Musik]
oder mehlwürmer haben die kapuzineraffen
besonders gerne etwa 60
kindergeburtstage organisiert sabina pro
jahr
[Musik]
klar du ri ist fertig für heute er ist
auf dem weg zum bauernhof seiner eltern
[Musik]
ich habe im sinn einmal den bauernhof
meiner eltern zu übernehmen
zuerst habe ich aber gelernt und war
mein vater noch zu jung war um den
betrieb zu übergeben habe ich fast watt
gemacht weil das mein zweiter favorit
war also eigentlich bin ich zufrieden
mit meinem beruf wenn ich nicht den
bauern rufen sicht hätte würde ich
wahrscheinlich auch nichts daran ändern
seine kinder verbringen ihre zeit meist
auf dem bauernhof
jetzt warten wir noch schnell bis die
mutter die eier eingesammelt hat überall
verstreut
neben schafen und kühen hat es hühner
schweine kaninchen und zwei ziegen hier
ein paradies für die kinder bezogen und
die kaninchen sind vor allem für die
kinder haben freude
es gibt hat sofort einen haufen arbeit
aber es ist schon schön
alle helfen mit juli ist ein friedlicher
mensch
ihm geht es am besten wenn es allen wohl
ist um ihn herum
man will es allen recht machen
der familie im forstamt man will es dem
vater der mutter auf dem bauernhof recht
machen und es geht gar nicht dass allen
recht zu machen
das ist etwas was ich gemerkt habe man
hat manchmal zu viele eisen im feuer und
kann gar nicht alles machen und ich mag
keine halben sachen
auf der landstraße richtung weinfelden
ritter fährt einmal in der woche zu
ihrer mutter in den kanton thurgau wo
fühlt sie sich mehr zu hause
im mittelpunkt aber durchaus zu einem
wort oder in dem film haben wir doch
nicht so tut als rückzugsort zum
energietanken hier hat rita zwischen 14
und 20 gewohnt jetzt legt ihre mutter
mit und alfi alleine hier ihre ältere
schwester anita ist leicht geistig
behindert und lebt in einem heim
aber die drei haben eine sehr enge
beziehung und nutzen jede gelegenheit
zeit gemeinsam zu verbringen ihre
familiengeschichte hat sie
zusammengeschweißt
der vater hatte beide töchter
missbraucht
rieter war sechs ihre schwester 14
als die mutter sich von ihm trennte und
anzeige erstattete
wir selber sind nur sache dann wieder
für und denyo den herrn den hits hat
mengenproblem keine schulen mit wissen
der sache und dann an ideen über
psychologie counted sind sachen führen
konnten
es ist wie wenn du das jedes mal wieder
muss verzehr den hang jetzt darauf
regeln einmal zur oberstufe mit ihr über
das ist für die mutter war es ein schock
sie quälte sich jahrelang mit vorwürfen
minute war es völlig das studiert
aber es bringt aber du bist nicht
durchschnitt dafür dass das passiert ist
neben sinne schulen naja ich kann ihn
dafür dass mir das passiert ist märz war
passiert aber ich tue mich aber trotzdem
wieder lange mit dem gedanken dass ich
weis oder das ist halt passiert und dass
ich das kann vielleicht ein schwieriges
starker aber trotzdem mache ich jetzt
das was ich mache ich mache es gerne ich
mache mir aber gar nicht ich liebe es
lieber ich bin glücklich ich bin happy
und ja
[Musik]
zurück in maria so
das funktioniert irgendwie ins ob es ist
fütterungszeit
neue phase fünf bis sechs kilo am tag
und hat eine drei monate hat sie pause
entleeren und ist eigentlich es nach
hanau von der natur in der natur denn
sie hat sehr viel auf einmal ab und auch
an den garten zwei wochen aber auch bis
sie die nächste blüte cleo muss viel
essen sie erwartet nachwuchs
die zweieinhalbjährige löwen kommt vom
platz holen frauenfeld
max stammt aus dem letzten wurf 4 vor 14
jahren
es ist das erste mal seit seiner geburt
dass es sind sowie der löwen babys geben
wird
[Musik]
in verarbeiten vater und sohn zusammen
so gut es geht eigentlich haben mein
vater und ich eine gute beziehung
die zusammenarbeit funktioniert gut es
sind mehr die ansichten welche sehr
unterschiedlich sind
wenn einer wie bilder andré b das
nächste mal ist es umgekehrt
meistens muss ich nachgeben weil es ja
nicht mein bauernhof ist zum beispiel
versteht klar du überhaupt nicht warum
sein vater landkarten im stall aufhängt
hier seht ihr anschreiben ist diese
schwalben sind schon zurückgekehrt und
als die schafe gefragt haben woher diese
vögel kommen habe ich es ihnen auf der
landkarte zeigen können dass die sie
jeden tag anhören müssen
nein ich würde solche sachen nicht im
stall aufstellt nicht wahr
das ist schön wenn mir das kommt kann
ich ihn manchmal etwas erklären oder
nuri und auch leon
[Musik]
260 kilometer entfernt in sulden im
kanton thurgau ritter liebt es gemeinsam
mit ihrer schwester anita zu kochen wenn
sie bei der mutter sind
ich lebe ganz und anita dass sie so eine
sanfte seele hat und nehmens ramacher
und sie wird dass es alle das ist allen
klar ich mache und ich denke mir immer
ich habe mir eine große liebe für den
abschnitt super damit den klimaschutz
einkochen und dann sagen und das ist
weiterhin bleibe dass sie sich
entspannen aber sich natürlich immer
wieder führen und fragte sich was mir
wichtig dass ich mit meiner mutter noch
die kreise müssen ihre großchancen könig
lear andere länder bieten als nur die
kanarische insel
das war mir wichtig dass ich das noch
machen solange ich um mich herum an
[Musik]
40 kilometer entfernt auch in appenzell
gibt es nachts
dpa
eine kaufen versprochen dass hans jörg
seinem familienleben so sorge trägt hat
einen speziellen grund der sohn heißt
unsere mittel unterwegs
ein erster frau hätten den mods und nach
dem schlagen
minute später die begegnung wanderer und
erich gegen kuba andere und die nachher
gelbe trikot wahr machen und den
annexion kommen schon mal nicht ich bin
sagen wir mal einen machen und das
wunderbar tag lerne ich denke jetzt bin
ich glücklich wenn sie so stolz
positiv
[Musik]
feierabend sind so von maria so auch bei
sabina ist es anders gekommen als
erwartet
also schon mal so übernahm sie jetzt
länger durch das erwartet und bin jetzt
einfach die kraft hätte ich einfach
jetzt funktioniert federico wollte
eigentlich keine kinder
heute kann er es sich nicht mehr anders
vorstellen
[Musik]
es ist halb acht
klar du ri wohnt mit seiner familie im
dorf so lange sein vater den hof noch
führt er und seine frau natalia haben
sich im konfirmationsunterricht
kennengelernt als sie 18 waren
wir haben halt stück hinter bekommen
24 war ich damals und es hat sich
herausgestellt dass es gut funktioniert
klar die hilft zu hause viel mit es gibt
schon genug zu tun mit rein
gerade jetzt auf wen muss man die ganze
zeit aufpassen weil er keine gefahr
kennt du stellst doch ab und zu etwas an
[Musik]
wie es halt so ist natalia arbeitet noch
30 prozent im spital von stoll
es ist doch noch etwas was man dazu
verdient aber im moment ist es fast so
viel dass sie auch noch arbeitet aber
wenn sie jetzt für drei vier jahre im
spital aufhören würde käme sie nicht
mehr in den beruf zurück das wäre
eigentlich auch schade
in sulden bis das storno fertig was die
drei frauen erlebt haben hat sie eng
zusammengeschweißt
alle themen und probleme werden am
familientisch diskutiert auch das später
im moment single ist krieg und ihres
dritten überlegenheit des die anderen
bezirke sich sagt sie ich bin jahrelange
bezirk sie für sich sah
und da sind viele singles sehen und
jetzt ist es eher umgekehrt jetzt mir
noch nicht singen aber sie ist okay für
mich im moment das stimmt das so nicht
zu spaßen politik will der auch so
arbeiten sieht wenig und das
kennenlernen mit dem kann
[Gelächter]
in appenzell gibt es noch abendprogramm
die schweizers musizieren regelmäßig
zusammen
[Musik]
wollen
da gab es doch den ärgerlich weil man
natürlich spielen
dennoch wenn es danach gekürt und macht
mit den höher gelegt und dennoch nichts
war frei durch doch sein widerpart
stunden wenn man kein lächeln
miteinander gemessen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
seine kinder bedeuten ihm alles hier
ruft sie haben nicht so detainee oder es
lieber so gestaltet dass wirklich aber
mal ein schöner ort sind egal wo es
einen schlager und vielleicht auch in
der familie how das ist einfach das
ganze sehe und job wohl bald sehr
wichtig die kapelle bienengift hat sogar
schon preise gewonnen
[Musik]
am abend haben sabine und federico den
zug ganz für sich
das ist auch jene für die machen alles
und geschlafen ich wurde dazu laufen
auf die doppel
okay sie
so
es ist 8 sabina ist und jede minute froh
in der sie ruhe hat
[Musik]
darum ist es ihr im moment noch so recht
gleich mit lisa ins bett zu gehen
[Musik]
abend in der schweiz
ja klar du ri ist ganz zufrieden mit
seinem leben so wie es jetzt ist kann
ich sagen dass ich eigentlich alles
richtig gemacht habe vielleicht die eine
oder andere kleine sache hätte man
anders machen können aber alles in allem
würde ich sagen ist es gut so wie es ist
gute nacht schlafe
morgen stehen sie wieder auf und mit
ihnen mehr als acht millionen andere
menschen in der schweiz jeder mit seinem
alltag und mit seiner geschichte nächste
woche kommt carly fährt mit dem postauto
in die hintersten täler des tessins
dünne schöne betreut in der region biel
kranke kinder zu hause porsche
siegenthaler ist kranführer im berner
oberland
meine batterien arbeitete in der
uhrenindustrie und hat sich nach der
kündigung selbstständig gemacht
[Musik]